hergé le grand est mort mais jamais
tintin ne s'est porté aussi bien leur
éditeur casterman multipliant les
rééditions et les nouvelles
présentations de la poule aux oeufs d'or
que sont les vingt trois albums traduits
dans le monde entier
ainsi deux au pays de l'or noir qui
reparaît en fac similé de l'édition
originale celle de 1950 assez
sensiblement différente des suivantes
tant du point de vue de l'histoire que
de celui des illustrations
non
l'or noir a d'abord constitué le
feuilleton de l'hebdomadaire belge le
petit vingtième de septembre 1939 à mai
1940 il y est constamment fait allusion
à un conflit menaçant ceux qui lors de
la parution de l'oeuvre en album dix ans
plus tard ne gênera personne
on est alors en effet en pleine guerre
froide quant aux allusions aux
événements de palestine attentats
israéliens ou présence de la grande
bretagne
elle se justifie d'autant plus qu'israël
est né dans la douleur en 1948 lors noir
demeure un des très grands livres de la
série pour d'autres raisons
il présente des personnages mémorables
comme le cheikh bâ bel air
l'émir ben kalish ezab et son
insupportable fils abdallah ou encore le
senor oliveira de figuera que l'on
retrouvera dans d'autres albums
certaines scènes ils sont prodigieuses
quant à la mise en scène ainsi des vrais
faux mirage des dupont ou encore de la
visite clandestine ou docteur muller du
très grand art